So the answer, the first one is a valid string; it
has a double quote followed by another double quote, and a sequence
of characters between the double quotes. The second one is not
a valid string, and the reason it's not is because it starts
with a single quote, but ends with a double quote. A
valid string must start with the same kind of quote it ends
with. The third one is also not a valid string, and
the reason for that is it starts with a double quote but
there's no double quote that closes the string. The fourth
one is a name, this is a variable, it's possible it
could be defined to be a valid string, but without defining
Ada as some string, it's not a valid string by itself.
The surprising one, might be the last one. This
is a valid string, it starts with a single
quote, it ends with a single quote and it's
perfectly okay to have a double quote in the middle.